dia is looking to buy a plot of land to
build her home on she finally narrows
her search to two plots that have both
have good locations the plot at 314159
apple lane has a width of 30 meters and
a length of 40 meters the plot at 11235
fibonacci drive has a width of 50 meters
and a length of 20 meters they're each
being sold for 36 thousand 000
which one is a better deal
so they're the same price and they're in
comparable neighborhoods so really the
the better deal is the one that i
actually have gets gets me more area so
i encourage you to pause the video and
think about which one of these which one
of these am i getting more land for the
same amount of money
well think about how much land i'm
getting i'm really thinking about how
much space is my that plot taking up or
i'm really thinking about what is the
area of each of these plots and we've
already figured out that you can
calculate the area of a rectangle by
multiplying its length times its width
so the area of apple lane
the area of apple lane is 40 meters
40 meters times 30 meters
which is equal to
40 times 3 is 120 40 times 30 is 1200 or
and then it's meters times meters or you
could view this as square meters
square
1200 square
meters now let's think about what the
area of the plotted fibonacci drive is
so it's 20 its length is 20 its width is
50.
so here
here
the area
is 20 meters
times 50
meters which is equal to
20 times 5 is 120 times 50 is 1000
square
meters
so it's pretty clear when you calculate
the area that apple lane you're getting
more square meters than you would get at
fibonacci drive and literally when we
say 1200 square meters that means if you
were to put if you were to put a one by
one a one meter by one meter square here
so a really small one like that that you
could fit twelve hundred of these on
this plot of land while you could only
fit a thousand of them on this plot of
land of these one meter by one meter
square so we have a larger area
same neighborhood or comparable
neighborhood for the same price i would
go with apple lane being the better deal